là d'où je viens et des règles tu vois
tu me prends quelques jours je te prend
quelque chose la police est bien suivez
même règle est pas tu pourrais me
laisser prendre ta voiture un soir cette
fois qui fait ça un toilettage quoi
situer et commence aujourd'hui à l'école
de prix il s'en sortira très bien
papiers du véhicule
ce vaccin
je vais parler sans détours d'après les
résultats de l'enquêté les policiers
impliqués ne feront l'objet d'aucune
poursuite
ils disent que si jay avait une arme et
avait accès à tous les dossiers
provisoire monfils été tuées par le même
policier qui a tué le tir j'aimerais
savoir ce que vous comptez faire
[Applaudissements]